bonjour david les parlementaires sont
plutôt réfractaire à ce nouvel
allongement de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire de trois mois et demi des
facteurs c'est le mot sophie elle sait
tout cas la volonté de la majorité et
l'état d'urgence sanitaire devrait durer
jusqu'au mois de juin puisque le
parlement s'apprête à donner son feu
vert cet après midi ici au parlement une
petite partie est des parlementaires de
la majorité est contre pour ce qui est
de l'opposition cette prorogation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire est un nouvel
affront fait aux libertés fondamentales
écouter on a eu l'habitude de l'état
d'urgence pour des questions de
terrorisme qui a été inscrit directement
dans la loi finalement on est dans un
état d'urgence permanent et pour nous
c'est extrêmement problématique parce
que c'est liberticide et que surtout ça
donne les pleins pouvoirs à l'exécutif
et je crois que au contraire on aurait
besoin d'avoir beaucoup plus de
démocratie sanitaire de démocratie en
pandémie et choisissent de le faire par
l'autoritarisme le conseil de défense et
un président de la république qui décide
seul
je crois que c'est une très très
mauvaise solution que ce qu'ils font un
homme seul décide de mesures privatives
de liberté c'est pas un état d'urgence
sanitaire par hasard c'est que on oblige
les gens à rentrer chez eux à 18h et que
c'est pas ratifié par le parlement en
angleterre en israël le parlement décide
là c'est fini c'est un suicide du
parlement les français vont juger et à
terme il va bien falloir trop d des
questions pour qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
que président de la république rendre
des comptes
et en mars 2020 pour rappel ce régime
boîte à outil permet d'instaurer toutes
les mesures telles que le couvre-feu
actuel ou encore est la fermeture des
restaurants réinstaurer depuis le 17
octobre dernier le parlement l'a prorogé
jusqu'au 16 février d'où la nécessité de
ce nouveau box vous l'aurez compris en
tout cas tous les groupes politiques de
l'assemblée
or majorité on l'annonçait en votes
contre ce nouvel allongement est de
trois mois et demi principal argument la
lassitude de la population et le
ras-le-bol des restaurateurs station de
ski ou encore à des étudiants les
menaces de désobéissance civile font
également partie des raisons évoquées à
gauche comme à droite
ils dénoncent une banalisation de ce
régime particulier
merci beaucoup pour ces précisions david
khalifa en direct du palais bourbon